this Pro Rage Quit out of a match
because of units that weren't even there
so way back in the early 2010s idra was
the bad boy of Starcraft 2 and his
biggest arrival was the game squeaky
clean Golden Boy Huck during their match
at MLG Dallas in 2011 idra was about to
take a commanding 20 lead his army was
so much bigger all he had to do was
attack but wait hu used an ability to
create fake void Rays a unit that if it
were real would have countered raid's
entire Army if it was real the void Ray
all hallucinations doing absolutely no
damage whatsoever and idra left the game
oh oh my goodness idra and in the next
game Huck had to let him know look idra
went on to take the series 4 to2 this
has to be one of the most embarrassing
moments in Esports ever